round one of the London chess classic  the last stop on the grand chest or the  best chess players on the planet  descended on the Google offices to begin  their battle for the 2017 Tour title  five-time world champion Vishwanath  on-on-on seemed to have a Cara Nakamura  on the ropes in a topsy-turvy affair but  the wily Americans spun the game around  with some brilliant defensive moves and  the game ended in a draw tour leader  magnus carlsen press mightily against us  number one  Fabiano Caruana but the world's best  player missed a couple of chances to win  leaving him feeling frustrated after the  game obviously a bit disappointed since  I was pressing the whole time I also  have to give props to him for a good  defense it's tied at the top as the  players look to see who will be the  first to break through with the win  round 2 action live from London starts  right now